I am Kung Fu Panda 3 because it's so
good it's so good I just want change my
baby punk come to Fanta 3j said why are
you in the white you know you go see it
go see it right now join them listen to
its introduction it's so good just stop
we're doing gose here cuz it's amazing
these movies just get better and better
if I got just go go go see it I'll just
go but we will be talking about norm of
the north and this is sibling rivalry so
norm of the north great movie or the
greatest well I mean just what a
surprise me all the crew wanna give like
a literal zero percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and here it's an incredible
film
I think that's being gracious yeah I
mean it could clearly he was a panda
which was a little misleading in the
advertising and you know there saw this
kung fu vibe to it I really didn't get
anything from the north per se but uh
yeah really a solid film I almost felt
like it was a third in a series a
definitely Rob Schneider's best work
regginator is the ball newbies your
Vinny dirt dude there are so many people
asking me to do that for like an
astounding norm of and or about like I
don't know yeah now for me the grief is
still Tanner I have to say we're trying
to keep it like actual nostalgia base
for light when we do newer films like
you'll have two songs which I'm just
getting off a cold so I probably sound
like shit
well I mean there's how you could tell
the difference but but I mean what can
even say about this film it's just it's
so good I mean in my opinion it's a
series of films that just how are we
talking about norm of the north or come
in literally norm of the north gate
clear okay uh no we are talking about
cut it if anyone is legitimately
confused we are talking about Commander
three um but yo just say it's normal the
nori on your ties
yeah put the norm of the north poster
and the the image of us you know um this
is you know we should talk about we what
we thought the previous films
uh first Kung Fu Panda look like shit
but was surprisingly really good and
visually in tries you know if I'm not
mistake was that the one you dragged me
to kicking and screaming yes and he
think of it he tells me this and it's
like George Costanza when he's crying
over home alone and Seinfeld walks in
and he's like what are you crying were
home alone like comes in and he's like
yeah and he's like you've got to see
this movie you gotta do okay what movie
is it come through Panda to my kung-fu
Panda that's the title alone yeah
because I saw the trailers and it's my
job though don't you be fair every
single trailer for this goddamn serious
look like horseshit
total fucking horseshit and every one of
these movies has been good so whoever
the marketing people are for this you
should be fired what can you do how ok
I'm that to you and every hyzer yes how
would you analyze this movie and make me
like I want to see that but the first
movie was one of those you dragged me
kicking a screen man like I don't
believe you I told you start baile I'll
fucking believe you
fine I'll see this for myself I came out
and I was like I literally was like
humming the the kungfu fighting song and
was like okay that was amazing so then
the sequel comes out we're like okay
looks terrible lightnings struck what
I'm sure they can't they can't how they
gonna do possibly and then looking
peacock is the villain are you yeah
come on and it's even better than the
first uh and the fucking peacock is
legitimately intimidating yeah so what
you know what you make a peacock
intimidating but they did it so then so
now this third film comes out I kind of
have in my mind that okay these last few
films have been phenomenal I mean just
wonderful animated the bottom has to
fall out it yeah like oh nope I'm
thinking like until myself is gonna be
good but don't be disappointed if it's
not very good you know just another way
it's a game of throne don't get too
attached and sure enough it was I mean
it it's hard to say cuz I just got out
of any we've literally just got done
seeing it but I mean it might be my new
favorite of a3i that cold so it's a
little difficult like laughing like haha
you I thought we're literally gonna fall
out of the chair I think there were kids
staring at you but you were laughing so
this body art this writing is so good
and so tight and it doesn't that just as
fucking tighter and tighter every new
film yeah cuz the second one I thought
the writing for the most part was you
quick later yeah and this one it's is
it's as tight as you can get it you
remind me of Hot Fuzz a little bit like
there's so many jokes being thrown at
you and they build on top of each other
it's not just and they come back wait oh
yeah stuff you think is like oh that's
just for the little kids or something
like it comes back into the story
reminding a lot of Hot Fuzz they sort of
do a similar thing where they had these
jokes that you think your can throw away
jokes but they're actually part of a
greater joke going on that in turn is
also part of developing something great
with these characters and actually kind
of thoughtful with the characters so
like practically every sentence is
either there to make you laugh and it
succeeds or if it doesn't make you laugh
it's there to make you feel to make you
feel something for the characters and
that works um and you know again with
every single one of these movies it
seems like hey we're not going to just
tell the same story again we're going to
actually evolve the characters
specifically Poe played by Jack Black
he's going to you know in the first Phil
he's becoming you know the Dragon
Warrior you know whatever and then in
the next one he has to really hone his
skills to take on this villain yet to
discover his past and then in this one
he's becoming a teacher and every single
one of those Russian yeah every single
one owes it's like you know if they
really did that right those would be
interesting and they do it right and
they do it funny and outside cuz we're
not that far with How to Train Your
Dragon so it's hard to compare them yet
but if you if you put How to Train Your
Dragon aside this for DreamWorks is the
closest thing to the Toy Story series
they have in a story that is really
should not have been as good as it was
like they're like Toy Story could have
just been a quick knockoff like some
little Disney thing they did was
incredible and the story progresses with
every movie and has now gone through
this full kind of story arc that was
really freakin amazing and this is
DreamWorks is answer to it and I I
honestly think it's just as good like
this is this is as close as they've come
to really competing with Pixar outside
of How to Train Your Dragon which I
can't really put in there yet because
we're still going in that one yeah this
film feels like to a certain way that if
they need to wrap it up here they can
yeah so until I hear otherwise I'm
considering it finish I know their
master plan was they were going to be
like we're gonna do like nine of these
meals like six movies or something I
love it don't get me wrong if they had
decided after this one we're gonna do
six more after seeing this one I'm like
go for it like I can't like this all the
things so the only thing I'm worried
about is that at some point like the
bottom is gonna fall out of will yeah
any that's like but this was not good
but this was not the example of what
could go wrong this is an example that
they could still keep doing it and it
could still work amazingly but
considering that DreamWorks right now at
least as far as I can tell if the news
is correct seems to be in the shitter uh
this bit this may either be the final
one or we may be able to pull one more
out it depends where DreamWorks goes
from here I yeah I'm really a
but if this ends up being their swan
song this film because this will feel
self-contained enough what roles will be
there so on sigh Oh doesn't that look
amaze without brief you for this stupid
movie I'm like don't show this before it
come to Panda 3 guy you know the worst
thing you could do is show it after come
from canta 3 honestly that trolls
trailer was making me wish for the
Zootopia sloth trailer and that to me
may have been outside of norm of the
north the worst trailer I've seen all
year for an animated film everybody's
eye down then once again I do not think
that Zootopia it's not proof to me that
Zootopia is going to suck I know again
Zootopia could be great that fucking
trailer though if I ever see it again
this year
Oh cry said mi John I excited to sit
through that long joke and yeah it's
stupid finger Oh Steve I saw Star Wars a
couple times you had to sit through that
trailer every time you're just like shit
oh we're inside Jabba here um so so yeah
it evolves the characters that you know
that the comedy is really tiny the
writing's really tight and the fine
thing is you know with a lot of these
movies we've seen films that go too fast
don't focus on the right things just
want to get the jokes out there and
don't feel like they have any humanity
to it and they just they go go go joke
joke joke but they're not meaningful and
something about the way they do these
films they are tight and they are funny
but also it feels like there's meaning
behind every joke and they don't linger
well this holiday this is the tightest
one of all to the point that I wonder
sometimes if it was a little rushed
because DreamWorks might be in trouble
and they're just like get it out there
it certainly has been it's being
released in the dead sit like this is
the dead season yeah and I thought for
sure that meant this movie was gonna
suck cuz I'm like oh shit they're
dumping it in late January this is gonna
know it's a good movie but it is the
other two movies particularly the second
one I thought there were a couple of
slow bits there's not a single slow but
in this time it's almost a little too
fast maybe you could have slowed down a
bit
there's a gravy a little bit because I
was thinking the same thing particularly
when he discovers his family that this
is in the trailer he discovered this
family discovers all these other pandas
and it gets to a part where he's
supposed to be like training them or
they're showing him around and stuff and
I felt like so is this going to be the
whole movie just nothing but this
fast-paced stuff I was starting to get a
little tired of it but then immediately
after that scene it goes to him and his
father relaxing there and then he goes
and he tells him about his mother and
and his past and so on so forth and I
felt like that that was what I needed
that was when I need this slower seen
idea things to calm down a bit I needed
the emotion to come back in to a point
where they even played the most you know
heartbreaking scene from the last one
which I won't give away by me they
replay it
I'm like shit don't show the scene don't
show that's because it's just so they'll
do this to me man don't turn me into a
publicist um so I thought it actually it
balanced out just enough cuz I was
getting concerned - I thought balanced
out just enough cuz each film seems to
get a little faster and a little tight
for me it's somewhere between maybe a
little too fast and just enough but it
it's a small criticism how many movies
have we sat through we're just like just
literally just stare at the screamer
just like and fucking Android everything
at you and they maybe one will stick but
all the others are missing and this one
gets like the majority of them are using
hi the lights are twice 1o minutes kind
of like force awakens or some of these
other movies we've seen lately words is
like no you could have overstayed your
welcome longer you could have actually
fleshed this out it may actually be
better to a certain degree I'm so sick
of movies that are just way too long
that I'm like I'll still take that over
the opposite like if this movie drag on
forever
I've been like oh Christ like we just
move it along so I I would rather leave
wanting more because it went a little
too fast then leave going Jesus Christ I
wish it would have ended like an hour
ago
let me get Catholic with fury road every
choice that they make is so particular
and explain something about the
characters or about the humor about the
story or the backstory um and it's
interesting because I
you're talking about with films that
feel too long because I used to love
longer films I still do I like films
that really take their time but again
they're done right and yes if they want
to get a sings corrected they have to do
it for the right reason it has to be
telling you something has to continue to
explore something or explain something
or make you feel something Pirates of
the Caribbean 3 yeah or like I have
never like I really they are oh boy at
the beginning of that movie I wanted to
hang myself by the end of pipe yeah I
mean it feels like that where they think
like this is good long and big is good
and it's not oh a well you know under
certain circumstances but you know what
I mean oh it's so busy trying to tell
you this is important this means
something this is big enough it's not
like we're decide it's important yeah it
but it doesn't execute any of it well
yeah like shamans another great example
some of his longer films where you're
just like this could have been told in
like an hour and a half and we're still
fucking going Elijah
Michael babe which house keep on some
Michael Bay film yeah ok where is this
like this is like true was it fucking
transformers 2 which one had that big
desert battle and I trying to well they
don't weren't - I'm loving this an hour
and a half movie and we're at like the
three-hour mark just stop it shut up and
go home and just end this movie um but
this film I think a lot of it too is
because I even the lines I mean a lot of
the lines are sort of like they're very
short philosophical sayings that mean
something and tie in to what's going on
the story it's not just hey let's just
shout a random philosophical why not if
nothing can you imagine if this were a
Lucas prequel film or Wachowski brothers
film half of oogway's lines would have
been these paragraphs going on for 40
minutes yeah I mean the idea it's like
don't you know the more you take the
less you have but one sentence and if it
was no no Gary wachowski or Shyamalan it
go on for like a paragraph or a fucking
quick Tarantino it's been doing that a
lot recently recently okay it says
always but he could kind of make it work
for Ojai I did when he executed well it
can work but like whenever I look up
like that I had to look up Tarantino
lines for something and like there it's
funny because half of them there's no
line
it's paragraph yeah um and this was just
so tight and so precise um and but in an
Asian they demonstrated it visually it
was one line was the accompanying visual
and then told you everything you need to
know just like fucking fury rub like
good the same thing like it's some of
these I feel like particularly in
animated films it's like they have
remembered that this is a goddamn visual
medium you know what else I love about
they respect it even though it's a it's
a CGI film they obviously respect
hand-drawn animation they respect the to
details but the simplicity of the flat
picture of the simple shapes because
they with each film I feel like it comes
back more and more broad bigger
cross-cutting they're doing yeah Bonta I
mean a lot of those backgrounds are
walking abandoned that yeah the thing I
love the most in the first one they
never abandoned it they're like this is
awesome if I think they brought it in
more yeah uh you know it feels like a
lot of times a lot of backgrounds even
though a lot of times is
three-dimensional it looks beautiful
they also know the value of these very
flat landscapes but these very simple
wave skis we're all yet to do is move
one or two things but just the placement
of them and the simplicity of where
they're set if you are so much is he
meant the best one of the most gorgeous
set of animated movies you'd see in the
past few years this fucking cunt Ravana
Ida laughed in your face but it's true
every single one of these movies is
rendered gorgeously the use of lighting
of shading of the ambience of the
texture like every single thing there
are moments that like in a cheaper
animated film they just would have done
all this under a blue sky know what no
we're setting this at dusk or we're
setting in this guy judges so much like
the color scheme changes so often and it
always reflects the mood it always
reflects the feeling of each scene you
know that's what's so great about
animation is you can do that and I got
to imagine it's more expensive and
time-consuming to render all of the
light because you're talking about dusk
and dawn like the sort of golden hour of
lighting when the lighting just has to
be so perfect and it affects the entire
landscape where you could have just done
it under a fucking blue sky like
recreating that I would have
imagine is easier but no it's they
always pick these gorgeous backdrops I'm
liking it a fucking come from Panda yeah
like these movies have been way better
than they ever should have had any right
to be
yeah I mean and it's I think because of
that I mean even though these films do
well and I'm sure this one will do fine
if this is a series of films that like
you want kind of telling my wife yeah
you wanna go see funk come from pain to
three oh I guess I mean is though
usually we trying to spin to three but
then I had to remind her of the other
two feel like remember we saw the first
Bell yeah we thought was gonna suck you
it's good yeah mer we saw the second
Phil yeah that's really sad and it's
like yeah I'm like you remember this
because it has the title Kung Fu Panda
and Jack Black and all these celebrities
and all these American catchphrases and
stuff but it's like they use it right
and they do it right uh and I don't know
it's a classic don't judge a book by
it's cover and it's a weird picture cuz
it's really infectious Lee fun I left
the theater just like I did the other
two would just I know the second one's
kind of sad but still just with this big
dopey grin on my face like like coming
out of like the original Star Wars or
something you just you feel like a kid
again it's like that was just a lot of
freaking fun and reminds me a lot of
Avatar The Last Airbender how it's like
they're mixing this comedy but also this
really good classic philosophy and
that's the secret and they're teaching
it to little kids and the don't we get
it too it's really fucking a doll like
I'm still surprised like when I think
back particularly the second film I'm
like this is some heavy stuff they're
talking about here you know and it the
psychological aspect to all three of
these movies is way more intense than I
ever would have expected going in I just
would have thought it would have been
like fucking norm of the north or
something this is going to be just some
one-liners and just some stupid
slapstick and like no there's actually a
really deep psychological undercurrent
to all of this
it's much both those first two films in
the segment in particular we're way more
adult than a lot of freaking adult films
I see oh yeah so I I think the only
thing I wouldn't describe it as by any
means a weakness I would say it's more
like if I really have to nitpick
I think the villain in the second film
is probably the best this one is
definitely better than the first one the
first one I think was the week as part
of the movie was the villain this is a
good villain JK Simmons plays in
immediately it opens up with this really
cool backstory and and like it shows
what this guy can do and yes this great
voice and these great lines uh I think
it's one of those things where it's like
you're not gonna beat that peacock that
sounds insane but the peacock from the
side if it was her so intended I think
part of what they did was I think almost
intentionally they weren't trying yeah
whether or not that's the right move or
not I couldn't tell you I can tell you
this
um the villain in the first one played
by Ian McShane and the the peacock in
the second one played by Gary Oldman
we're both legitimately threatening like
I found them legitimately scary like I'm
an adult so but as is somebody watching
a kids movie I'm like mommy's these guys
are legitimately intimidating not once
did I get that out of this this bold
spirit character played by JK Simmons um
I don't know I got out of I thought I
thought yeah but here's the thing though
they weren't playing ian mcshane scare
achter it was a tie long or the
terrorism whatever his name was they
weren't playing him for comedy this one
they're intentionally playing it is a
conscious choice we are making this
character funny oh I'm this guy who
wasn't I didn't like any thick aspects
though I mean what do think today was
like huh what huh hey I'm at the
Ambassador you know that was the end
might be give him acquainted are his
fucking that I'm sorry his foot like the
the Thailand's escape in the first movie
was too horrifying like it was amazing
it's funny too but he doesn't say
anything funny you're right no doesn't
say anything funny there is no attempt
to really make him Gary go ahead on
funny wine get a few funny lines ah no
you're right it was more reactions to PO
himself like I can't believe it this guy
you thought this was the weapon this
he's still kind of there's nothing funny
about him as a character I wouldn't say
this guy is straight-up laughs I still
thought he was legitimately kind of into
his moments but they cannot have fun out
of all three villains as far as being
scary he was the weakest I didn't take
him that seriously despite the fact that
physically he may be the scariest of
them all like I thought what he could do
with stealing the characters Chi turning
him into these Jade characters I'm like
that's really scary I almost wish he was
in one of the earlier films where they
didn't make him funny because I'm like
man this this guy could really fuck him
up um but so yeah I I kind of think
that's the only real weakness in the
movie otherwise that it's not it's
really more just compare the other day
it's a nitpick you know he's still fine
but part of it is I think the rest of
the story is so strong that the villain
kind of suffers by comparison were the
other two you know the villains I felt
were much stronger but they shot
arrested the story wasn't as well put
together the thing I loved about this
one okay I loved the first two movies a
lot the only thing I didn't like about
the first two movies is I thought they
were building up this whole kind of
Taoist thing like this we way sort of
doing through down action and oh it's
because PO is a panda and because he is
sort of dopey and lumpy that it gives
them this this sort of advantage he's
not your typical kung fu warrior and I
thought they were going to do that the
whole way through and like particularly
in the first one I thought well you know
I guess spoiler alert if you had like
healers but we keep moving it's not just
that it's that they started off the
whole fight with Po getting his ass
kicked but the thing is it doesn't
bother him he's so fat and so clumsy and
so used to getting knocked around and
bouncing around that I thought oh this
is clever Thailand's gonna literally
tire himself out
like this is a perfect statement of that
sort of Taoist message and are going for
we're by being useless you actually
become useful instead in fucking stead
he like literally like comes up bases
like I don't know he's like oh I taught
myself the secret move like it's like
weird you met well taught myself like
skadoosh in the funny thing is like yeah
I had to think if I were a kid with this
is so bad I mean yes yeah no he was on
why the menapii huts we never saw him
fucking even try to learn it like he
gets it used out of once he's like oh no
that's the finger trap moving and that's
it it literally is the very definition
of a deus ex machina they fucking just
pulled it out of nowhere and I'm like
and the funny thing is you didn't need
to do it there was a perfect ending that
would have fit with the whole philosophy
of the movie now it's a minor gripe but
it is something that did bug me in the
last 30 seconds iPhone because I thought
it was doing such a good job of pretty
much coming up with an alternate
alternative way that this guy could be a
kung-fu master without actually being a
kung-fu master and the second one is
that I think it works okay in the second
one you really have some issue I still
unlike it in the second one I still
thought like where is he learning some
of these physical techniques that he's
just pulling out of his ass basically
like just like I'm gonna board the
Cannonball and whoosh whoosh whoosh
whoosh ah you see Morna you see him with
like the Michelle Yahoo character and
stuff like that you know and the
raindrops and everything and confronting
his past as my like I felt like they
address that okay I in find it as bad as
the first movie it still kind of irked
me I still felt like yeah you guys keep
writing yourselves into a corner and you
have other ways to come out of this and
you're not taking it I feel like you're
kind of abandoning the philosophy that
you're celebrating at the last week just
going in Magica was a difference but
that this one brings it all on issue
with the teaching and the dis one it
actually worked and I was so grateful
because I was so sick of like Oh what
always do the finger trap finger good
and skadoosh you know it's gonna be
something pulled out of his ass this
time they make the entire final battle
all mental and spiritual in the
spiritual world which I guess is his own
conceit so you have to accept that you
can go to the spirit world and there are
ghosts and this and that but if you can
accept all that to begin with this is
of disbelief here is way less of a
problem I'm actually like this works
it's all mental it's more of a statement
of faith and in this in that design and
then physical going on here this all
works as a metaphor why and the great
thing is again I mean not just it's the
connection a family connection a friends
connection of you know fathers and
brothers and sometimes up and it's him
as a teacher has come through it's not
what he is physically daughters do when
they did that well because just like how
they were setting up the first film with
maybe it's the uselessness or whatever
his natural ability is and that's what
Shifu had done he's like oh well you're
obsessed with food we'll use that to
train you he looks at the other pandas
and the are we doing a spoiler corner
yeah I mean what will do a light you
know well oh just lightly without giving
away to my me I think we know he's not
gonna die at the end or anything we
basically just uses the other pandas
natural abilities as kind of a
distraction sort of thing he's so he
doesn't teach them how to be great
kung-fu masters he just teaches them to
use their natural talents in a way to
distract Avella and it it works much
better than in any of the previous two
films or it's like he's like now I'm
just gonna set the fag and aggurlie
become fanatic so we're gonna but he
three amigo did phase yeah it's
basically been dreaming and it works in
that way because the villain wouldn't
see it coming and the two entities you
know all the are pandas and po are very
naturally teaching themselves even
without them realizing that they're
teaching one another and I think you're
right I was probably the message that
was almost starting to get worked in
with the first one that never quite
happened and here feels much more
realized and much much better that's the
message I wanted in the first two and
they finally did it and I'm very
grateful for that because I'm like okay
see this is the point it's not that
you're going to instantly become a
kung-fu master or physically like Arnold
Schwarzenegger he was basically telling
him not all a bunch of fat asses let's
find a way to use that to our advantage
what natural talents do you have and he
basically used it to their advantage
that's what the first freakin movie
should have done and the second and it
never really did
then we finally got it I'm like just
thank you I was so worried they were
gonna do it again but um yeah so the
first two like great villains
I thought the endings were the only
weakness is this one okay villain I
thought the ending was actually really
strong yeah um so yeah there it is uh I
think these are wonderful films if you
like the first two you'll like this one
I it's definitely that same style but
it's not just a repeat they do move it
on and they evolve it um and even this
even the side characters like James Hong
the guy who plays the duck yeah I think
he's the unsung hero of this whole
series he's got such heart no he really
didn't my scare occurred or definitely
do I felt so but there's something about
him in particular I felt so bad when
Poe's father shows up that beautiful
animation where he's like how do I know
you two are related and like they start
belly like Bali bombing each other so
because you just see him in the
background then that NECA visit his face
just or you know I mean and everything
about I don't know just everything about
identity and family and where you come
from where you belong and how it's all
connected and everything it just felt so
right this just felt like the right
humor the right animation the right
message the right philosophy the right
acting I felt like this was a complete
package yeah this like the first you
were so close to being one hundred
percent perfect now maybe we finally got
it I mean maybe the villains not that
strong but we got two stronger villains
before so we'll just ride that wave and
um so good ending so yeah that's about
it obviously you can very quickly see
our reactions to it uh a lot for those
wondering Steven universe VIII logs and
real fun to be back yeah where we're
coming back this week like obviously a
lots been going on so now we're getting
back into the swing of things so this is
sort of the start of us moving back back
to normal again
so uh yeah guys go see it it's so good
and we'll see you then take care
skadoosh